I come to this video with black playing
Grand Master riccardi from Argentina so
two out of five against the sky and
we're going to have a spanish opening
yeah I wonder my wood passive line or
okay I'm giving it a whirl once again
I'm sorry guys it is my bread and butter
opening in Blitzer my mask was not bad
people keep criticizing that for being
too passive and rightly so but still I
am I'm not scoring went badly with it
they keep making mistakes like Bishop h6
it's not it just it's not it's not a big
mistake but it's a small one allowing me
night f7 shortly okay I'm taking that
hmm you just continues but it's a piece
maybe it's in my latest live stream and
things okay again this guy I can do
anything but it's a piece I'm going to
ok vago Bishop here mmm i can go age
five year actually let's do that prevent
any unite jumps no problem with that
move right here can I should use my my
extra material so cannot win anything
directly here we take it rook cheeks and
their fire trying to open up with f1
yeah for looks like a good move
counter-attacking
so I can take f3 now I think cooking
takes it's not really necessary i can
also take here ng3 I mean takes Queen g5
takes on f to take g6 all right we'll
win but I can also just go back that's
the easiest takes takes Queen takes 95
and he explodes on f3 yeah it just shows
that even grandmasters can sometimes one
move blunder pieces
I don't know of no particular idea why
is continuing we don't have any special
history or anything but ok you can
always continue if you like I mean why
why not so um let's see I can also just
go move that night and protect f4 so
that I can take with the rook without
any tactics or anything double on their
file something like that I may be here
cannot go G for him and take it
I really don't think I'm going for the
quickest to win you or anything but it
should be sufficient rook takes a force
also a threat so look g6 I can take on
edge phone
yeah I don't see how we cover the h-bomb
okay like that um I can take f3 or I can
also just in Cabo g6 maybe this is the
simplest way just cover that and next
move Queen e7 picking up the edge bone
can also take it now i can take f3 or
whatnot okay let's take that check okay
um Queen to e7 or whatever what is he
going to do then Butchie 50
maybe you look you fire
I had even dead as a move as weird as it
looks but he's totally self-penned huh
he moves the king i can go bishop the
sound neither for Queen g5 just doesn't
that's no problem
quite resigned yeah okay just goes to
show him if he just he just gave gave
away gave away that piece for no
particular for no particular reason
White has to um yeah drop back into 283
or something and that maybe runs into I
know I had five years night h6 stuff no
yeah he has to go back I mean I don't
think that this is particularly great
putting the bishop there but okay it's
not just the normal relatively normal
position yeah and here you just handed
me that piece yeah and I played it I
think okay I don't think there was ever
anything special happening maybe it was
an idea to him to involve the Queen a
little bit a little bit earlier but ok
that was winning yeah I was I had this
hunch but I couldn't really wasn't
totally sure but ok that wins young
knight takes challenge eggs King
Teague's I've got 27 ok I came then then
then this really wins he has no and he
cannot do this Chad left three so that
was was even quicker but ok it's a piece
yeah so there's no big reason to to be
fancy about it the way I played it it
was a rather rather technical let's say
oh yeah clinical affair nothing
spectacular but win is a win is a win
and yep that that lifted me back into
somewhat more normal reading areas ok
well thanks for watching